ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman we're going to start today with
this continued fiasco involving the
january 6
trump riot commission it is absolutely
stunning what is going on and what has
happened over the last 24 hours although
not altogether surprising if you've been
following the republican party
for the last several years so yesterday
i told you on the show
that um house minority leader republican
kevin mccarthy had selected
five republicans to be on the new
version of the january 6th commission
which will investigate what the hell
happened
on january 6th now remember
this commission is instead of the one
that was proposed originally
months ago which republicans said
absolutely no to
and as i pointed out yesterday at least
two of the five people
selected by kevin mccarthy congressman
jim jordan
and congressman jim banks are
effectively
insurrectionists now what i mean by that
is they weren't saying
go to the capitol right now on january
6th
but they were participants in the
ginning up of
doubt about the election results in the
months leading up to january 6th
which had people so fired up and almost
like in a feverish state of arousal
where they just went to the capitol and
did the riots and attempted the
insurrection on january 6. so
effectively you were going to have
insiders investigating the insurrection
that they incited now
good for her speaker of the house nancy
pelosi
decided to bar jim jordan
and jim banks from being on the
commission
and considering that the only reason
that jim jordan and jim banks were going
to be there would be to derail
the investigation to distract from the
substance
and to talk about other things like the
george floyd
protests of a year before or whatever
the case may be
i think it's great that nancy pelosi did
this now i know there are people who are
going to say well nancy pelosi is
terrible
whatever your opinion of nancy pelosi
this decision i agree with they were
putting insiders on the panel
to investigate what they incited it's
absolutely crazy
the associated press reporting house
speaker nancy pelosi
rejected two republicans selected by
kevin mccarthy
uh mccarthy said the republican party
won't participate in the investigation
if democrats won't accept the members he
appointed
pelosi cited the integrity of the probe
in refusing to accept the appointments
of jim banks picked by mccarthy to be
the top republican on the panel
or ohio congressman jim jordan the two
men are outspoken allies of trump whose
supporters laid
siege to the capitol that day and
interrupted the certification of joe
biden's win
both of them voted to overturn the
election results in the hours after the
siege not a trivial detail
democrats have said the investigation
will go on either way
pelosi said she spoke to mccarthy and
told him she would be rejecting
the two names okay good so what do
republicans now do
they again frame themselves as the
victims let's
take a look at a press conference that
kevin mccarthy did
and let's listen and then we will
discuss
we will run our own investigation right
we have law enforcement we have military
we have doctors we have people from all
walks of life
they want to know the answer the
american people deserve that they don't
deserve politics
they don't deserve destroying the
institution no committee
in congress will work if one person is
picking all who can serve
now of course it's not true that one
person is picking all who can serve
uh and it's not true that it is a uh uh
that it's exclusively a democratic
commission three
of the five people that kevin mccarthy
selected
nancy pelosi has no problem with nancy
pelosi has also selected a republican in
liz cheney to be on the committee
so that it would be bipartisan even with
kevin mccarthy pulling everybody
but liz cheney is the wrong type of
republican and we'll get back to liz
cheney momentarily but the most
important thing to remember
is that the initial structure of this uh
investigation
that was proposed months ago was by
definition
bipartisan and republicans rejected it
the initial setup was going to be
ten members uh democrats choose five
republicans choose five every subp the
democratic
member would be the chair a republican
member would be the vice
chair and every subpoena sent out to a
witness
would have to be signed off on by both
the democratic chair and the republican
vice chair republicans rejected that
entire framework
and we're going to get to hear why that
was
and the revisionist history around that
listen to this
mr leader you're complaining that you
don't have a bipartisan
opportunity here to investigate january
6th but you stood in the way
of a bipartisan commission right made up
of independent members
right yes you did
uh your conference voted against that uh
at least a majority of your conference
voted against it and it was blocked in
the senate
why did you not allow that to go forward
listen to this what you
say you want is a bipartisan
investigation to what happened on
january 6th
for the same politics pelosi played then
at the same time when she used the scope
of that
remember how long it took on january
13th
rodney davis and myself both requested
a 911 commission even those who ran the
911 commission
criticized nancy pelosi for what she
wanted to do
we had officer evans killed on good
friday but she said you couldn't look at
that
if you study the 911 commission they
didn't study what happened on just
september 11th they study what built up
to it
but she said no you could not do that
now this is maybe the most deceptive
framing of what happened
understand that what republicans wanted
to do
when the commission was initially
discussed months ago republicans said
we want to study the context but what
was the context republicans wanted to
study republicans wanted to include
in a january 6th commission the protests
during the summer of 2020 over police
brutality and the killing of george
floyd that's what they wanted to make
the january 6 commission about
which was going to make it a complete
and total distraction republicans
wanted to include in that january 6th
commission
the killing of steve i'm sorry the
shooting
of steve scalise in 2017
why because they wanted to make the
entire thing about
here are all these different instances
of people going too far
but mostly it's democrats and people on
the left going too far
nothing to do whatsoever with the
january 6 commission
and the context that republicans wanted
to include
in the january 6th commission was a
defense of the claim
that the election was not really won by
joe biden
why because if republicans in the
january 6th commission
could make the case that the rioters
were
right to be upset about the election
results because it really was stolen by
joe biden
it would in a sense justify their
violent actions on january 6th and nancy
pelosi rightly said we're not going to
do that
that's what kevin mccarthy is talking
about that nancy pelosi rejected
it's completely dishonest and now i
don't know what's going to happen
mccarthy's saying they're just going to
do their own commission okay uh liz
cheney by the way
i don't want to rehabilitate liz
cheney's image as i've said before liz
cheney's a horrible
republican who voted with trump like 90
of the time she just disagreed on this
one thing
uh here is liz cheney saying actually
the two people pelosi is not allowing on
the commission
their behavior was disgraceful she's
right not to do not to allow them
there are three members that the
minority leader proposed that the
speaker did not object
to she is objected to two members
and the rhetoric around this from the
minority leader and from those two
members has been disgraceful
so liz cheney because of those comments
being called a republican in name only
she's not really a republican how can
she say that
asked again she says i agree with what
nancy pelosi decided
you personally did you personally urge
the speaker to take the step
i agree with what the speaker has done
and then also
asked about the specifics of why she
thinks these two shouldn't be on the
commission
she said the following at every
opportunity the minority leader
has attempted to prevent the american
people from understanding what happened
to block this investigation right today
the speaker objected to two republican
members
she accepted three others she objected
to two
one of whom may well be a material
witness
to events this is a key thing
the republicans want investigators
who are really more witnesses and
participants
in what took place it led to that day
right led to january 6th
the other who disqualified himself by
his comments in particular over the last
24 hours demonstrating that he is not
taking this seriously
so liz cheney is on the same page as
nancy pelosi
liz cheney is no great hero she's a
republican who agrees with trump on just
about everything but on this
issue she is actually seemingly doing
what she believes is right
so that's the latest with the commission
which is just becoming a complete
joke of a situation thanks to
republicans let's now talk a little bit
about how republicans are reacting in
the aftermath
of this commission falling apart from
the standpoint of it actually being
something republicans will participate
in meaningfully
so we laid out we had the first january
6 commission months ago
proposed and rejected by republicans we
then got close to another one
but then when nancy pelosi said jim
jordan and jim banks they can't be on
the commission
they're part of the problem republicans
went nuts
now they're saying they're going to do
their own commission and
it's an absolute and complete joke the
reaction from republicans
and the right-wing media to this has
been to start pushing
new conspiracy theories about what
happened
on january 6th laura ingram
running on fox news a
headline called nancy the
insurrectionist
pelosi exploits january 6th in a
ruthless power grab
because she said two of the five
republican choices can't be on the
commission
remember that republicans could have
gone forward with the commission as
proposed months ago
and nancy pelosi wouldn't even have had
the power to reject any of the choices
of the republicans
then the right-wing media continuing
tucker carlson actually inviting jim
jordan onto his program last night jim
jordan is one of the members of congress
that nancy pelosi said no this guy's an
insider he can't be on the commission
um and pushed the conspiracy theory
still baseless
that the riots were a setup by the fbi
christopher wray refused to get on a
conference call about
preparation for january 6 before it
happened
they knew it was coming they didn't
protect the building they let the
protesters in
the fbi has a long history of setting up
crimes they just now remember
every single one of these things has to
be looked at in detail there was
the videos of law enforcement moving
aside
it's a typical crowd control thing where
when the crowd is overwhelming the crowd
control measures and the crowd
controllers and law enforcement
to a certain degree it's typical
that those doing the crowd control
will move aside and sort of like allow
the perimeter to be
shifted because it starts to present a
danger
to them as well as to the people to the
public that
it's it's not it's not the big smoking
gun that these republicans want to make
it out to be the big smoking gun is
trump
refusing to actually allow the national
guard in for hours despite being asked
did it in michigan we're going to get
into it in a second why isn't there
a good faith investigation into the
fbi's behavior or do republicans somehow
trust the fbi
well tucker you may remember a few weeks
ago when we had the fbi
director in front of the judiciary
committee i asked him about what
happened to the hoopers
up in the in the state of alaska who
were their door was kicked in
they were handcuffed that held at
gunpoint and interrogated for four hours
they weren't even in the capitol okay so
that's the that's the idea that the fbi
this is the reaction okay to the
commission the fbi
set it up then laura ingram does a
segment
with kevin mccarthy where mccarthy
starts floating this idea
that it was nancy pelosi that was
responsible for the national guard not
being there
when the riots were going on and the
national guard were there and nancy
pelosi was criticizing
because they were they were at the
lincoln memorial protecting it
was there a decision made by the speaker
not to have the national guard
at the capitol that day when they found
the that's the new one
it's it's not trump that was pence
mccarthy everybody's saying send in the
troops and trump saying
no as he watches this from the white
house now they're saying it's all
pelosi's fault that's what it is
and uh jim banks another one of the
insiders floating the exact same idea
jordan and i would ask the tough
questions that they didn't want to
answer about the
the systemic breakdown of security at
the capitol on january 6
and ultimately who's responsible for
that the speaker of the house
they don't want to go there they knew we
were going to ask the tough question
so that's the concerted effort you can
just see they've decided this is going
to be what we're going to talk about
let's say
it was nancy pelosi responsible for what
happened and then lastly uh here is
tucker carlson
attacking harry dunn the black police
officer who was attacked by
rioters on january 6. it's beyond the
pale information
what's the answer of course she doesn't
have one speaking of disingenuous
so the committee will proceed with one
party what will look like we'll think
msnbc with subpoena power on tuesday
pelosi will call a capital
police officer called harry dunn dunn
will pretend to speak for the country's
law enforcement community
but it turns out dunn has very little in
common with your average cop
dunn is an angry left-wing political
activist whose social media feeds are
full of praise
not coincidentally for nancy pelosi
here's a picture of the two of them
together racism is so american
harry dunn wrote a one post that when
you protest it people think you're
protesting america hashtag
leave it to whites to tell blacks what
is racist hashtag
i stand with elon omar hashtag squad
harry done ladies and gentlemen just
another fact so the support the police
people
now attacking the police victimized by
the trump rioters
on january 6th these people cannot be
trusted to investigate
obviously but they can't even be relied
upon
to provide even the most fundamental
unquestionable facts so
we'll see what this starts to look like
next week we'll save much more probably
on monday
remember that monday august 16th is the
16th
anniversary of the david pakman show
we'll be doing a one-day membership
special
i'd love for you to participate get
notified
on the 16th simply by getting on my
newsletter
at davidpakman.com
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back ground news
is one of the first things i would use
to get my head
in the game and prepare myself for the
interview because ground news is a news
source comparison platform
that lets you compare how outlets from
the left right
and center are reporting on a story it
makes it easy to see the nuances of how
sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spots stories that your side of the
political
spectrum may not have covered ground
news can help you
build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with
or ground news can help you discover
something new
about your own perspective challenging
your own strongly held views on
political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the free ground news app today
by going to ground dot news slash
pacman remember to grab a membership and
get instant access to the bonus show
at joinpackman.com we do an extra show
every day
on today's bonus show we'll talk about
the ben and jerry's situation
big ice cream drama uh that many people
have asked me to comment
on joinpakman.com sign up today i want
to point to
some interesting threads that appeared
on the david pakman show subreddit you
can join the discussion along with
more than 32 thousand can you imagine 32
000 of our viewers and listeners
currently subscribed to the subreddit
find it at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t one post says
right now i feel like covid will never
end in the united states
it's looking more and more like covid
will never end due to anti-vaxxers
and i feel pretty hopeless about it it
essentially means it's just going to be
one lockdown after another that i'm
never going to get
to meet new people again and vaccinating
the world won't happen either
right now i feel like ending it is all
it ending it all is the only solution
because of climate change and covid
never ending extremely depressing post
extremely
depressing pose uh we are going to get
past it
at a certain point everyone will either
be vaccinated
or will have gotten sick of course the
effect of the
variance is a question mark but it is
only
a matter of time the question is how
much time is that going to be um
but we are going to talk momentarily
about now even republicans all of a
sudden
saying hey it's it's time to get
vaccinated so don't lose hope don't lose
hope
um i do uh i am sure we are going to get
past it it's just a question of how many
people are going to die in the meantime
and what is what is going to come next
another poster
uh posted a clip from sam cedars show
majority report
where george w bush says that it breaks
his heart to see troops removed from
afghanistan i don't have too much more
to say about this i've already said
before
yeah we broke it and when you break it
you have some responsibility to stay
until it's fixed but it's very clear
we're not going to fix it
it's very clear that just staying longer
in afghanistan because we're the cause
of the problem
is not likely to actually bring a better
situation to the afghani people
and at a certain point we have to say
listen it's been bush obama
trump biden it's time to get out it's
time to get out and uh this is just a
reminder
that even when george w bush says
something mildly reasonable when it
comes to his perspective on donald trump
we shouldn't see george w bush as much
more than the
neocon uh warmonger that we knew him to
be during his two terms in
office and then this is funny a little
more lighthearted a post appeared saying
congratulations for 16 years
i know i'm a few days late but i want to
congratulate david on 16 years on the
air
lasting four times longer than the
confederacy no you you're not a few days
late you're a month earlier it's
it's not july 16th it is at the end of
the day
on august 16th that it will be our 16th
anniversary so i love the sentiment i
appreciate it
uh but you're not late at all you're
actually very early and for that we can
all be very very glad
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit all right let's talk about this
bizarre change but welcome change over
the last
maybe 96 hours in which many
republicans and some right-wing media
figures have started talking about go
get vaccinated
the vaccine is good the vaccine is safe
the vaccine will keep
most people alive not everybody so
even though the headlines has been the
headlines have been
fox news goes pro-vacs republicans go
pro-vacs
people like marjorie taylor greene
people like tucker carlson they've
continued to do
the anti-vaxx stuff but there is a real
question which is
why is this all of a sudden happening
there's a great article in the atlantic
by david graham called
suddenly conservatives care about
vaccines
a number of leaders on the right
suddenly urged their audiences to get
vaccinated in the past day
why now and there is uh
there are a number of different ideas
proposed here
and the article goes through hannity
saying that you've got to take this
seriously
steve ducey saying if you have a chance
get the shot
it will save your life ben shapiro
saying get
vaxxed i did my wife did my parents did
newsmax ceo christopher ruddy saying joe
biden should be applauded for making a
dent in the covered pandemic
house minority weep whip steve scalise
who has had conspicuously declined to
get a shot
announced he finally did get vaccinated
and um there is a clear shift in tone
as david graham writes in the atlantic
article but it's not
exactly clear why it's happening
one suggestion as reported by cnn's
caitlyn collins was that there have been
regular high-level conversations
between the white house and fox news
regarding pandemic and vaccine coverage
but fox quickly denied that report
another possibility is simply that the
coveted search fueled by the delta
variant
is making some of these republicans
realize the hospitals are getting
overloaded
we could be looking at lockdowns being
reinstated here
as they are around the world and all of
a sudden
when the stock market dropped
precipitously on monday even though it
more than recovered on tuesday and
wednesday
republicans all of a sudden cared the
other
real possibility is that republicans
might be doing the math that many of you
have been doing who write to me and say
david if you have dramatically higher
vaccination rates
among democrats than among republicans
could this have an electoral
impact in the sense that republicans are
going to kill off
too many of their own voters because
they are the ones not getting vaccinated
and it will cause them to lose elections
like could it be as simple as
dead people can't vote i don't know
i don't know because even with that you
have the conspiracy of i got some emails
about this a couple days ago
people writing to me saying david you
people
aren't doing a good job of lying about
the vaccine
this is the view of a right-wing
conspiracy theorist it's a little too
suspicious that mostly unvaccinated
people are getting sick and dying that
must be part of the conspiracy and it's
like no
it's that the vaccines work really well
at preventing death
so it makes sense that it's mostly
unvaccinated people that are getting
sick and dying um a couple of uh
uh instances here of such a pro-vaccine
statements from people we might not
expect it from and then i'm going to get
to another possibility that might
explain what's going on
here's florida republican governor just
make it
you know known as covet jesus to some
people a guy who ignored every guideline
early on and said have
full capacity uh boxing wrestling
everything in florida
here he is making a lot of sense um so
here's i think the the most important
thing with the data yeah
if you are vaccinated fully vaccinated
the chance of you getting seriously ill
or dying from covid
is effectively zero if you look at the
people that are being admitted to
hospitals
over 95 percent of them are either not
fully vaccinated or not vaccinated at
all indeed
and so these vaccines are saving
lives they are reducing mortality
mortality in nursing homes since we
rolled out the vaccines in december
is down over 95 so a really really
strong
pro-vaccine statement and it could be
motivated again by the fact that florida
has had a big upsurge and now represents
the one state of florida
is one out of five coveted cases in the
entire country
here is mitch mcconnell pleading for the
vaccine
get vaccinated leader mcconnell on that
note
there are the the republican governor of
utah said this weekend
that conservative talking heads are
quote literally killing their supporters
um would you speak out against people
who are actually speaking out
about the vaccine i don't know how i
could be any more clearer
than i have been i've been saying the
same thing about vaccinations
all along the way others can
say whatever they choose to say but this
is something i think i'm a good example
of
something i know the answer to it is not
at all unclear that the way to avoid
getting back in the hospital is to get
vaccinated i want to encourage everybody
to do that and to ignore all of these
other voices
so what do you think explains this what
do you think explains the change you
know
if it was only fox news even though
they've denied conversations
with the white house has there could
there have been some promise of access
right this is how stuff works listen
we will give you a joe biden town hall
if you guys really help us promote
vaccines
that would be completely plausible the
way media works
but it's not just fox news that's doing
it and also fox has denied conversations
with the white house they may be lying
but
let's assume they're telling the truth
is it as simple
as republicans are realizing that it's
disproportionately their voters that are
dying is it simply motivated by
self-preservation
i don't know the answer but i'm curious
to hear from you
what do you think explains this change
in tone and remember it's not a total
shift
even during these last few days we've
still seen the anti-vac stuff
from some republican members of congress
from some on fox news so it's not a 180
degree change
but it is definitely a change in tone
let me know your thoughts
we'll have more about this on our
instagram which you can find
at david pakman show find me on
instagram
david.pacman as well
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to have back on the program
today dean baker who's a senior
economist at the center for economic and
policy research and also a visiting
professor at the university
of utah uh dean we we spoke about a year
ago most recently
and uh we now have a very different
situation
from the standpoint of the pandemic
economically
what are you most paying attention to
and what is of concern at this point
well the economy is recovering rapidly
and that that's a very good story i mean
we still have a lot of people out of
work we're still not back to
what we might consider normal certainly
far from full employment
but to my view the question is the rate
at which we're going
and the extent to which we see obstacles
one of the big things or the big thing
of course is the pandemic itself i mean
we have
uh the numbers way way down because
primarily because of the vaccines which
have been great but we know there's a
lot of people who don't want to take
them and as a result of that they're
getting sick there
so that's a bad story now as it stands
i don't think there's a big economic
problem with that i mean i don't want to
trivialize people getting sick and dying
that's a big deal but i mean if we're
just talking about the economic impact
i think that's relatively limited the
big concern
and you know this should be a huge
warning to us we of course are talking
about the delta variant and
the vaccines are still effective from
that but as long as the pandemic is
spreading out of control
not here i mean obviously we care about
here too but
around the world we're not going to be
safe and that's a really really big deal
so i wish we had done i wish we still
now do more to get the world vaccinated
so that's a really really big story but
the other part just how
things look in the economy right now
well we've had fantastic job growth the
last four months over six hundred
thousand a month
um we're going to we'll get a gdp report
next week and the second quarter is
almost certainly going to put us above
where we were pretty pandemic i mean we
have a wage to go yet to be back on
trend
but most things are looking pretty good
and so
you know as the economy goes i'm feeling
pretty good about it you know we just
have to make sure we could slow the
growth of the pandemic
partly here but probably more
importantly right now around the world
there's been this um refrain or talking
point call it what you will
in the context of this enhanced
unemployment benefit
that the federal government established
during the pandemic
that now as things are opening there's a
worker shortage
businesses are having trouble finding
people to work
because people quote would rather sit at
home and collect their enhanced
unemployment now
we have some early data from some states
that decided to
get ahead of joe biden's september date
and just cut the enhanced unemployment
early
it's not totally clear that it's really
having
a definitive impact actually on
the the rate at which people are
starting to look for jobs or being hired
generally speaking my view is most
people want to work
and most people find for better or worse
they find meaning and identity through
work and that could be a bad thing or a
good thing we could talk about that
but that the kind of free rider the
people who just would prefer to sit at
home and not work
are so so small in number that they're
not significant
what's your sense of that talking point
yeah well you know everyone's got their
lazy cousin who's sitting at home
collecting benefits and they
extrapolate the whole world and that's
how many lazy kids out there actually
exist but in any case you know everyone
could
say they know someone and some people
surely are but
there's been a lot of research on this
and remember we had 600
a week supplements back in the original
cares act right and there were a number
of efforts to study the impact of that
and they found it was very little it
wasn't zero i mean obviously there's
some
people that will make a difference for
but there was relatively little impact
and you mentioned that now you have
several states that have
jumped the gun or whatever term you want
to use they've suspended ended the
benefits early
and my friend aaron baze at the
university of massachusetts he
analyzed what the performance has been
in the states that have been to benefits
early compared to other
states and there's no difference in fact
i think there's a very very small uptick
i'm not going to blame it on that but i
think they actually
had somewhat higher unemployment or rise
in unemployment relative to other states
so the idea that that's a major factor
in keeping people from looking for work
i just don't buy it what i do think is
going on is you have a lot of businesses
reopening at the same time and the
biggest story of course is restaurants
that's the one that was
hardest hit right and now they're
reopening so they're looking all higher
a lot of workers at the same time
and it shouldn't be surprising that
that's that's not that easy that that
you know they're in a situation they
can't get the workers they need they're
bidding up wages i mean that's a good
thing in my view but in any case
um that's really not a terribly
surprising story nor necessarily a bad
story
and in any case it doesn't seem as
though the unemployment supplements are
big part of the picture
is it as simple as some others are
saying which is well
it's just now the businesses the the
employers
need to compete for the
apparently temporarily limited pool of
of potential workers
and this should just mean that they pay
more and then it'll solve everybody's
problem like is it that simple
it is i think that's basically a story
and some businesses say that well i
can't afford to pay higher wages
and i'm sure in some cases that's true
and you know look this is a capitalist
economy
and you know some businesses businesses
go out of business all the time i mean i
truly realize that i mean i know people
put their
put a lot of work in many cases their
life savings you know
so so i don't mean to trivialize that
but that is the reality
so in some cases we'll have situations
where businesses
just aren't going to be profitable and i
understand they don't want to
say well if i get away with paying
workers 10 an hour rather than 15 you
know things
but sorry you know that's that's going
to be the world
and uh so so i just don't see this as
the big crisis that's being portrayed as
on uh the the other side of this
is pricing and inflation
during the pandemic we saw really
significant increases
in some products lumber but was a big
one
that had some sort of follow-on effects
in terms of
uh building of new construction homes
renovations
etc the price of lumber has now actually
dropped precipitously
although that drop does not yet seem to
have filtered through
as much as it maybe will to the end
products that the lumber is
is used for some of the inflation data
that we see
compared for example may 21 to may 20.
so you're sort of comparing to
when there was a significant demand
collapse and maybe that's not the right
way to look at it
what's your perspective on this issue of
inflation
well i think for the most part it's
reasonably well under control so again
the may to may comparison
or now we're in june to june but i mean
that's you know it's kind of silly
because it's you know these are bonds
where prices were badly depressed so
if you look at what inflation's done
since february the last pre-pandemic
month
it's up some there's no doubt about it
but an overwhelmingly large share of
that is simply
cars both new and used cars and we know
what the story is there
um there was a fire in a semiconductor
factory in in japan and that's led to a
worldwide shortage of semiconductors
which has limited the the production of
new cars
and what that's mean is people who have
money now from the the various
uh pandemic programs uh they want to buy
a car
um new cars they can't get new cars so
they buy a used car
and use car prices have just gone
through the roof they've actually begun
to fall by some measures as of june so
we'll see how that pans out over the
rest of the year
but that's the bulk of the uptick in
inflation so
it's hard to get too concerned about
that my expectation is that we're going
to see those prices
falling through the rest of the year i
mean they'll still be higher than a 220
level but they're going to be falling
from where they were
in june so i'm not that concerned about
that other areas of the new york times
had a big piece on housing
house prices sale prices have risen a
lot and that's because
a lot of people are moving that we have
very low mortgage interest rates and you
have a lot of people that are moving
from
expensive places like new york
washington where i came from and
they're moving to cheaper places around
the country and push putting a big
upward pressure on prices there um new
york and some of the more expensive
ones it's price growth is sloan in some
cases actually going negative
but you know but that's that's a big
story now whether that leads to
sustained increases in rents i think
it's a little too early to tell
i was struck you know this isn't
necessarily a good story but if we're
trying to tell the picture of the
housing market
we have to consider it we're ending the
the the
eviction moratorium that ends at the end
of this month
and their reports i think these are
exaggerated that somewhere around seven
or eight million people face eviction
i don't think anything like that will
actually be evicted but a lot of people
will be you know and again i don't i'm
not saying it's a good thing i'm just
saying
if we're looking at the housing market
and let's say we have eight hundred
thousand people victim pulling that
somewhat out of the air
but it will be a lot um that's a lot of
vacant units
um so you know it's again i don't mean
to say any of this is
good that isn't but we have a lot of
turmoil in the economy right now which
has led
inflation in some areas you know as
mentioned in cars i could identify some
others
but it's not an underlying it's not the
sort of inflation we saw in the 70s
where you had
higher wages driving higher prices
leading workers to push for higher wages
and then we got the spiraling upward
we're very very far from that story you
mentioned
in the car um discussion that
now part of this is people have money to
spend and they want cars as they they
get back to things
one of the interesting things that we
saw so to kind of set this up
pre pandemic frequently we would see
articles with headlines like
uh 40 of americans would need to borrow
to meet an unexpected
400 expense and about the the point of
those stories was very low
savings rate in the united states during
the pandemic
we saw headlines about dramatically
higher savings rate
in the united states at a macroeconomic
level
how should we think about that because
there's a school of thought
that keeping money in bank accounts
instead of spending it has a very low
economic multiplier
and is not so good for the economy
although at the individual level
certainly we can understand how having
an emergency fund
is a very good thing for a household
budget so how should we be thinking
about that
well there's two issues here one is if
we're thinking of just immediate demand
in the economy
that does restrain demand so if i have
you know i got my
1200 or 1400 check from president biden
and uh go okay well i'm going to put in
the bank because i don't need to spend
it right now
well if we're worried about inflation
that's actually a good thing
so so for word there's going to be too
much demand in the economy that's a good
thing
so i think as that has worked out it's
basically been a positive for the
economy in the sense that
as we're having this reopening and
there's a lot of
uh stress in different areas it probably
is a good thing that everyone
doesn't rush out and spending it now say
six months a year down the road as you
say
the the flip side the micro side is okay
i've got money in the bank i feel better
and we know i mean there's a lot of data
people's balance sheets are better than
they've been in decades
so things really look much better so
that's great both in their security but
also
maybe they want to do a big ticket
purchase maybe they're going to use that
money as
a down payment on a house or a car
whatever it might be
so i consider that overwhelmingly a
positive that
again if we're worried oh we need more
demand in the economy right now
then people saving is definitely a bad
thing but
we're not in that situation or at least
i don't believe we're in that situation
so
i'm very happy to see that a lot of
people are in a situation where they
could save
some of their money and again they could
always keep it there as a reserve or
they may decide six months a year down
the road to have a big ticket purchase
two other um i don't know if we would
call them trends or things that have
kind of
been topics of conversation as a result
of the pandemic one is
is work from home and the different
decisions that are being
taken by made decisions being made by
corporations about
we will do permanent possible work from
home or we will do
a split of work from home and be back in
the office etc that's one
trend the other one is we're also
getting more and more
information from these four day a week
work trials which sometimes
are a full 40 hours but over four days
and sometimes they're actually fewer
hours like a 36 or 37 hour week over
four days and looking at
what employee productivity is over that
period of time rather than 40 or 45
hours
what's your thought on these things uh
at sort of this point in time but also
bigger picture
i i think they're both very encouraging
trends taking one at a time
yeah the word from home clearly we're
going to see
way way more work from home than than we
did pre-pandemic i mean the point is
um you know business and nurse is an
incredibly and powerful force in the
economy
people have to appreciate that i for a
long time is an economist like oh maybe
it should be like this rather than that
and go well
maybe it should be but it's not going to
be well right once
employers got used to having people
working from home and they kept their
business operating
then they can't say it doesn't work they
know it works so we are going to see
many more situations where either people
are totally working
from home or cases where maybe they come
in once twice a week from the office and
and i think that's a great thing from a
number of different perspectives uh
obviously it saves a normal enormous
amount of resources on commuting
right um people's time i mean obviously
people value their time and if you're
commuting two hours a day one hour or
each way um
that you're you're wasting a lot of time
i don't know anyone i mean there's a lot
of things we could argue how much do you
like this or that
i know anyone likes their commute and
you know i'm sure someone somewhere does
but
i i think um i think just to interject
one idea there
there are some studies about if you have
a 15 minute commute
that it seems sort of for a lot of
people to be a positive kind of
change of phase from home to work and
that that
you know once you get longer than that
the duration of it seems to start having
like a more of a net negative effect
yeah i could believe that i mean a short
enough commute i
can grant isn't a big deal you know i
used to walk to work i was lucky enough
for
for a period of time to be able to walk
to work it was maybe half mile so
yeah you know rough you know 10 minutes
or so so yeah that was fine
that that didn't bother me unfortunately
i think the vast majority of commuters
have considerably more
time so so i think that's a great thing
and i think it's it's good of course
from environmental perspective uh
you know where people don't have
obviously a lot of resources are wasted
in uh
commuting so so that's a great story um
four day work week i think similar story
again if you compare the us to europe
um there have been sharp reductions in
work hours over the last four decades in
i was going to say most all european
countries and
we now our average work year in the
united states 20 25
longer than it is in germany and
netherlands denmark you know other
wealthy countries
and i think most people do value their
time and if we could have a four-day
work week rather than a five that's
great and yeah i'd love to see the hours
cut because i think a 10-hour day
certainly in a lot of jobs people would
find exhausting so
if we can make it a nine hour day uh
maybe somewhere down the road make an
eight hour day but whatever uh nine
hours isn't that much worse than eight
so
you know i think most people consider
that pretty good deal and again
getting back to the commuting if you
have four commutes rather than five
that's
that's a plus so i'd love to see us get
to shorter work years and a four day
work week's really good way to go
uh without a doubt i'm i'm with you
there dean uh we've been speaking with
dean
baker who's a senior economist at the
center for economic and policy research
also a visiting professor at the
university of utah
always great having you on well thanks
for having me on good questions
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
so yesterday i covered the blowup during
a senate hearing between republican
senator rand paul and dr
anthony fauci of the nih and during that
hearing dr fauci told
senator rand paul in no uncertain terms
that rand paul
quote doesn't know what he's talking
about and that if anyone is lying there
it's rand paul himself this apparently
has so infuriated rand paul he's on tilt
he's unhinged that rand paul now says he
is requesting a criminal referral
against dr fauci for allegedly lying to
congress
the intimidation that is being carried
out against scientists
and against medical professionals is
completely appalling
take a look at this from a recent rand
paul appearance on fox news
where he announced this which he seems
to be announcing almost like it's some
kind of badge of honor that he's willing
to take this
incredibly principled step you kicked
off
your questioning of dr fauci emphasizing
federal law
makes lying to congress a felony
punishable by up to five years in prison
is your belief based on the evidence
senator
that he lied before congress and broke
the law
yes and i will be sending a letter to
the department of justice asking for a
criminal referral
because he has lied to congress this is
an absolutely
ghastly and dreadful direction
for the country to go in and it's a very
very dangerous one
dr peter hotez posted to his twitter
a link to an essay from 1941 by
waldemar campford called science in the
totalitarian state
and it reminds us that the targeting of
scientists and doctors has a really ugly
history
in particular in the 20th century
remember that albert einstein
decided to go to the us at the very end
of 1932 eventually came to the united
states in 1933 and stayed
because of what was happening in europe
including
with reference to the world of science
and
attacks on science are simply a
totalitarian hallmark now
i'm not saying rand paul is hitler i'm
not saying rand paul is hitler
i'm not saying rand paul is hitler you
have to clarify these things
otherwise i will be very much punished
for the next 24 hours on twitter
this means that when we see scientists
and doctors under attack
for doing their jobs it should really
scare us
now fortunately the current department
of justice is unlikely to actually do
anything with this request from rand
paul under merrick garland
but what would a william barr department
of justice under donald trump have done
or
someone like trump have done in such a
case it's still a stretch
but it's within the realm of maybe
they'd look at whether dr
fauci should be charged with something
and this is
a really really chilling proposition
so in terms of the confrontation between
dr fauci and rand paul that we looked at
yesterday
i'm glad that dr fauci took off the kid
gloves i'm glad dr fauci
called rand paul out fauci he almost
looked uncomfortable doing it it's not
really his thing
but how else is he supposed to deal with
the just persistent attacks on science
and scientists
attacks on his morality attacks
on his ethics and unfortunately much the
way that
trump had this longer-term effect on the
coarsening of political discourse that
went beyond trump's presidency
the legitimization of attacks on just
basic science you know
masks and vaccines for example
it i fear and it seems pretty clear
that that is going to be seen as a
legitimate way
to attack science that the right doesn't
like
for a long time this is it's very clear
that this is now
a tool of the american right wing and
they can use it they can use as a cudgel
science is just opinion scientists are
just politicians
you can ignore empirical statements that
come from the scientific method
just like you can ignore uh one of your
political opponents opinion about
abortion
right they're making these things
equivalent it's not as i've said before
plea
don't don't hurt me i know this is i say
this often it's not about
we disagree as to what the facts are
it's they don't understand what
are facts what types of statements are
facts and what types of statements are
opinions
and it's not new in that for example
with climate change
they've been denialist for a long time
for sure
but the mask and the vaccine stuff and
even denying the basics of how
coronavirus works for a very long time
and even now to some degree
that's more than we can't yet say with
certainty
whether we are damaging the planet long
term like i
i think we are but that's a different
type of denialism
that's denialism but it's different than
the virus is
fake or masks do nothing
or the vaccine harms you or
this was created as a bio weapon in a
lab and deliberately released
the legitimization of that degree of
nonsense as being just as valid
as the science it's actually almost
post-modern in a sense
think about that because for
post-modernism has been a popular target
of the right now i've criticized
post-modernism as well but the way the
right does it
the right comes out and says
post-modernism is the marxist enemy
postmodernism leads you into
any any notion from whoever about
anything is valuable all this different
stuff
they are essentially doing a form of
that they are saying
our opinion about what coronavirus is
should be held up as just as valid as
what doctors think
our harebrained conspiracy theories
about vaccination
should be considered just as valid and
serious as
legitimate as what medical science says
it's a form of post-modernism and
post-structuralism in which they
are engaged it's a total hypocrisy
that shouldn't surprise us but it's also
very very dangerous
and uh you we should be glad that the
merrick garland department of justice
i can't imagine is going to take even
remotely seriously
rand paul's request for a criminal
referral
against dr anthony fauci last week i
told you
about a young anti-vaxx nurse
who got covered and died and i told you
i take no pleasure in that although some
people called in and said they do
take pleasure in that we now have
another one of these examples
linda cern former born selectmen
dies of complications of covid19
linda cern remembered as a staunch
conservative well-respected educator and
friend to many in the town of bourne
massachusetts died on friday due to
complications of covid 19.
cern 70 died at brigham and women's
hospital in boston of severe
complications
caused by covid she was brought from
cape cod by med flight to the hospital
in early june
and had been in a coma on a ventilator
until her death
she was not vaccinated against covid19
according to a close friend and one of
her neighbors
the article includes a picture of linda
cern
with a trump flag and a maga
hat from november of 2019.
cern was known for volunteering on
various boards and committees in town
she served three terms on the board of
selectmen etc etc
on the political side she was president
of the chapter 9 massachusetts
republican assembly
cern was one of the first members of the
united cape patriots
she was often seen hold oh frequently
held
trump standouts on the born rotary i've
driven by that i've driven by that one
going to martha's vineyard that's
interesting
she was often seen holding a trump
supporter support poster as motorists
drove by
honking in support or against um
lang was one of four people adam lang
according to adam lang lang was one of
four people who protested last week in
opposition to the state
vax bus which distributes covid19
vaccines
when it arrived in provincetown so some
people react to this by saying who cares
or even good
that's not my reaction i find this to be
a tragedy a tragedy of disinformation
and misinformation
some react by saying we should refuse
health insurance coverage to people who
refuse to get vaccinated
some people react by saying we should
refuse treatment to these people
which i don't think you can do that
would violate the hippocratic oath
that medical professionals take others
say we should charge these people
more and there may be something there i
mean listen when you look at
um when you look at life insurance you
pay more if you're a smoker for example
so it's not without precedent that
i don't know maybe we look at a higher
uh health insurance rate for people who
choose not to get vaccinated
there are serious moral questions about
it there are serious legal questions
about it for me the solution is
we just find a way to get these people
vaccinated that's really where i am and
maybe i
maybe i have too much empathy i don't
know um
but another victim of anti-vaxxerism
trumpist anti-vaxxer has died and
it's hard to feel good about it and even
if you don't care about her
how many people could she have infected
who were vaccinated either due to
low immunity as a result of being
immunocompromised or for whatever other
reason for me there's really nothing to
be happy about here
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
this is an interesting voicemail with a
with a historical question
how did the american right wing get so
crazy listen to this
hi david this is josh from maryland yeah
and my question is just regarding the
conservative
culture in the united states how did we
get here
how do we get to a point where 40 of the
country believes the wild conspiracy
theories
believes a citrus politician like joe
biden is a communist
yep and there's a massive misinformation
media industry
all right thank you the answer is a very
long one
and i've talked about this before i
spoke about this even with noam chomsky
not not that long ago
and if you wow i mean it's like how do
you even
you almost have to go back to the
creation of the united states but to
save you the really long version
first of all you can google
anti-intellectualism
pseudo-intellectualism united states
1800s there's a big anti-and
pseudo-intellectual movement in the
1800s which
you could say kind of is is the original
underpinnings
or catalyst for what we see today in a
more modern political sense
you kind of have this story that i've
told before and if you've heard it
before and and you don't want to hear it
again i apologize but
you initially saw big reactions to the
civil rights movement in the late 50s
early 60s that started to lead
to people's emotions bringing them to
believe and want things politically that
really made
no sense then that led into
the reagan era and people starting to
fall for
stories that reinforce their
pre-existing beliefs like about
welfare queens and so on and so forth
that ultimately led into the clinton era
we're skipping some steps the clinton
era of the early 90s
where in 1994 newt gingrich took over a
speaker of the house and sort of went
full bore on this idea that we might not
really need policy
the republicans of 94 still did some
policy but they did a lot of character
assassination and personal attacks that
started to go to the next level the next
step on the unhinged ladder
under george w bush george w bush is
kind of a sleepy doofus for lack of a
better term
um further created this idea that
even though he's a sleepy doofus this is
what it means to be patriotic
and a lot of people who were quite
ignorant rallied around bush
rallied around the iraq war rallied
around attacking iraq
because mostly saudi men attacked us on
9 11.
barack obama as the first black
president a half-black individual of
course
um basically got us off policy
altogether as far as republicans are
concerned and just on
this guy isn't even american this guy's
uh
muslim or [ __ ] as some of them like to
say uh
and we came that that's when the the
paul the the
even mere pretense of caring about
policy disappeared
and then trump and the q anon and etc so
you can trace it back to the start of
the civil rights movement in 58
you can trace it back to anti and
pseudo-intellectualism
in the 1800s you could even go back
further if you were so inclined but it
is a very
the fact that it's such a long history
is what makes me pessimistic
about the idea that we're going to solve
it anytime soon
on today's bonus show we'll talk about
the ben jerry's
ice cream fiasco we'll talk about a big
opioid settlement which we're going to
have a lawyer on to talk about next week
and we will talk about a gender reveal
party that sparked a wildfire
leading to 30 different criminal charges
i'm basically against gender reveal
parties and i'm gonna
uh hot take alert i'll talk about why on
today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com and i'll see
you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman